today i thought we'd talk about uh
internet standards and in particularly
uh the uh request for comments the
famous rfs
yes he referred here in there yeah so
they started out exactly what they said
on the tin as a request for comments so
the very first one
rfc number one was by uh steve crocker
who was one of the very early movers in
uh the internet at ucla and he published
that on the 7th of april 1969 as rfc one
and it really was a request for comments
it was like uh
we're going to try doing these things um
what do you think guys
exactly that and so he sent it around
to a few people saying here's a request
for comments have you got any comments
on
on this and then they kind of stuck
you know pretty much all the internet
standards well actually all the internet
standards are now got rfcs
behind them so uh tcp and ip they're
rfc 793 and 791
and there's a couple of other ones
around there they grew fairly slowly
because
there weren't very many standards to
publish in the early days and
but they they're coming quite aware now
so how does it work when one of these is
published how do the comments come in
that have been requested if right well i
don't know how they worked
originally in back in the early days but
nowadays you
you publish an rfc draft and you say
here's a draft and uh this is this is
what i want to uh
standardize or um some of them are
informational
some of them are standards like tcpip or
rfc822 i spent a lot of time with that's
the
internet mail standard and 821 which is
smtp
so some of them are just like that that
they're they define as standard some of
them are sort of
these are best practices or this is kind
of what we got
there's quite a number of them and i
have to say i've contributed to this
list that are just um
humorous and often posted on the first
of april or something like that
so i've actually got three with my name
as author
two of them are pretty obscure now
they were early days stuff to do with
x25 and tcp
and another one to do with network time
over x25
which nobody does anymore but perhaps my
most famous one is rfc 1606
which was an april the first one there's
a little bit of history behind it
so at the time um we were running out of
ip addresses
something that we're still doing to this
very day and this was back in
1990 something or other this was um
and the there's this big crunch coming
up that we're going to run out of
ip addresses any time now it's 1994
we're still not um we're going to happen
there's lots of reasons behind that
and they were discussing ipv6 which is
you know this
new version of uh internet protocol that
hasn't exactly taken well by storm but
it's sort of
gradually encroaching and there's a lot
of discussions i think there are about
six
proposals at the time that were internet
drafts and
would become rfcs and uh
they'd all got various suggestions about
it so
um you probably know ipv version 4 has a
32-bit
addressing so that means there's 4
billion
possible places that you can address and
that seems a bit limited you know given
us what eight or nine billion people on
the planet
if you want to give them each internet
address you can't actually do it but
we get around that with nuts and things
like that
so at the time we were discussing what
the ipv6
addressing should be and there were
various proposals there's
64 bits i think there's 60 bit
there's various other things usually it
was in powers of two because they fit
into words quite easily
and there were one or two that were
looking at 128 bit
things and at the time i wrote a
short article and which wasn't actually
published anywhere i just
posted it on the newsletter i think on
one of the groups
tcp discussions and uh
instead of saying no no this is silly we
should
we should think think ahead and uh
let's not go crazy let's let's
fix this once and for all that was sort
of my argument lots of other people were
arguing the same thing
so i thought i could write a sort of
paper saying no we should go for 128
bits because
um you know that's going to be far more
addresses than we ever need
because the original arpanet started out
with i think uh
256 addresses
they thought that would be plenty that
would be all the machines you'd ever
need
and then they realized it wasn't and
then they went for 32 bits and said well
you know four billion addresses that's
going to be more than we'll ever need
and then we came to e6 and they said
well you know 64 bits that's going to be
more than we'll ever need
and so i wrote a a rather spoof paper
which i called
the demise of ipv version 9 originally
but it got uh published as a historical
perspective on the usage of ipv9
and it was supposed to be a sort of a
22nd century look back at
why ipv9 was
having to be retired because it didn't
have a big enough address space
so i published this out as a sort of
tug-in-cheek article
and said you know the serious point
about it was
you know let's not make another mistake
and uh go with just
a small address space what's v6 is it
64. it's 128 bits
so there should be plenty to go around
for that
so that that was a good thing anyway
but anyway i published this out on the
network i think it was
sort of february or march time about
about an hour i guess
um just as a humorous thing and i
published
a number of similar tongue-in-cheek
articles that uh
nobody took seriously luckily but this
one was picked up by john postell who's
the rfc editor at the time
a really lovely guy who edited all the
rfcs up until
his unfortunate and timely demise i only
met him once
he lived on the west coast of america
uh anyway he he sent me a quick email in
response to this and said
uh i found it quite amusing or something
um
should we could we just publish an rfc
i said oh yeah yeah i guess you could
what do i need to do
to do that i said it's all done taken
care of
and julie on the first of uh uh april it
came out as this
ipv9 now the odd thing about it is
that when people are looking for serious
systems
like universities go out for tender to
uh for a networking thing
they often sort of go through all the
rfcs and say um
well which ones to do with tcp which
wanted to do with ip we'll make a tick
list
and say they should adhere to all these
standards and they often come across
mine and say oh i p version
oh yeah yeah we should definitely adhere
to that standard
and so i've had many queries over the
years since it was published saying uh
can i get an implementation of this iv
version nine
say you know well have you actually read
the rfc because
it's probably not something you want to
uh deal with
so some unwitting uh like uh system
implementer is has been told your uh
proposal must adhere to all these
standards and yeah
all these have got ip and then title so
you should adhere to them all you know
we all know rfc are standards but
there's actually about 30 or 40 humorous
rfcs that you should not
uh adhere to i mean there's a
one that predates mine rfc 1149 which is
a
transmission of ip datagrams over avian
carriers
so this is how to transmit tcp over
pigeons
and there has been actually an
implementation of that where you
print out the packet you attach it to
the foot of a pigeon you send it off you
catch it in the loft
you then type back in
now if if we go back to one of your
recent ones about pings and trace routes
they actually did a ping thing with this
the ping time was several hours or
whatever i'm going to say yeah
if you were lucky yeah that one has also
been cited in uh
you know proposals saying we should
appear to all the rfcs and uh
1149 seems to be to do ip2 so
let's get that i'd like to see that
implemented like wide scale it'd be like
harry potter or something
i think there's been an update to it to
actually improve the performance of it
what people do with their spare time is
quite
quite weird what do you have to do to
make an rf6
unless you're doing one of these
humorous ones usually you form a group
and you get together particularly if
it's something that's crucial like
internet mail or tcp ip or ipv6
you know ipv6 they deliberated about for
several years before they uh
came up with they picked the one version
that they were going to go with and went
for
so usually you form a group you form a
working group you publish drafts people
comment on the drafts
you revise the drafts people comment on
those
they argue about them they add features
a bit like any other standardization
where does the numbering come from
though is there like a is there someone
that hands out a number for you yeah
normally you just get the next number in
the sequence so
now a few of them you do get special
numbers so when they revised rfc 822
which is internet mail standard
it was coming they were in the 2000s at
the time and they waited to 2822 so it
got 2822
i think it's being revised again or
they're always tinkering adding little
bits on to them sometimes they replace
the entire standard and they say it's
now being
deprecated and it's been replaced by
this one so in that case you know rfc
822 was replaced with
2822 which was nice and memorable and
sounds like it's crying out for a block
train solution oh yeah
yes could could well be i don't know
that
probably somebody has considered that
who knows
now what if there was a secret
mathematical relationship between p and
q would that change anything
what if p was actually equal to some
multiple of q
like this now with different time to
lives
you can find out every hob on your
journey
very neat